[Musique]
dis-moi une chose est-ce que tu penses
aux enfants ce qu'ils ont pu devenir oui
oui oui ça m'arrive de temps en temps et
[Musique]
toi et maintenant une histoire
extraordinaire qui vient d'être révélée
au sujet d'un jeune homme qui est allé
il y a bien longtemps visiter Prague il
a découvert là-bas des milliers de
réfugiés abandonnés et à la mercie de
l'invasion imminente
[Musique]
d'cller il y a des enfants ici qui
vivent en plein air dans la
boue ce que j'ai vu rien ne sera
l'effacé un déplacement massif d'enfants
qui n'ont ni argent ni visa écoutez nous
devons tout faire pour croire que ça
peut être
possible il y a un millier d'enfants sur
cette liste alors on va activer tout ça
vas-y tout de
suite ce doit être très difficile pour
vous sachant ce qui est arrivé à tous
ces en en fait je ne sais pas ce qui est
arrivé notre émission est loin d'être
terminée j'ai une question il y a-t-il
quelqu'un ici dans ce studio dont la vie
a été sauvée par Nicolas
winon tu sais bien les
sauver il va bien falloir que tu te
pardonnes
[Applaudissements]
ça qui sauve une vie sauve le
[Musique]
monde